of course our parents say that they love
you all equally they treat all the
children the same but all middle
children know we are forgotten about I'm
the second child of four at one point I
was the second child of three and then
my youngest sister surprised us and
blessed us I am the middle child of one
of five I guess here that's considered a
pretty big my parents are both
originally were born in injuria so they
had bigger families I'm technically a
middle child my dad had a sudden from a
previous marriage and then when he got
with my mom then she had my younger
sister I have an older brother and a
younger sister I am very much like
Stephanie from full house I'd say Thank
You Stephanie Thank You Stephanie Thanks
I definitely got plenty of attention
from my parents but when I was a kid it
never felt like enough when it came to
minds in my parents relationship they
sort of like knew that I would be okay
it was always Oh take care of the baby
or oh it's the oldest you have all this
responsibility that you're supposed to
do and then the middle child just kind
of floats in between there was one time
I went to my sixth grade dance my
parents said that they were gonna come
pick me up and I was the last kid
outside and just sitting like I had no
boat to call anybody it traumatized me
so much would they have done that to my
younger sister absolutely not they would
have been there at five o'clock when the
dance ended there are a lot of home
movies of me trying to get as much
screen time as I possibly could you can
definitely tell when my sister was born
because once my dad started filming her
instead of me I would throw myself in
front of the camera every time he was
filming her when the middle child like
tells you something like believe them
because for the most part there's a lot
of things that the middle child is just
trying to get across like look see this
and a lot of people don't pay attention
I think in me to my siblings like I was
always the weird one they would get
along with each other like really fine I
always want to sleep early
so they would stay up watching movies
and playing video game I sort of ended
up being like the third wheel
I wanted the respect with my siblings
even to this day that is something I
want more of growing up when I was
younger they did not look to me at all
so the curse of the middle child my
older brother my younger sister are
pretty close they tease me a lot about
how organized I am and how clean I am
how I'm always nagging at them to clean
up after themselves but they always know
that they won't do it and so then I will
so they kind of abused it a little bit
they get me to do stuff that they don't
want to do I've always kind of felt like
sometimes they do kind of pick on me
when my brother came around we would
just bump heads didn't tell everybody
about the years of torment that I put
you through I've never got to see you
very often and so I would always be this
close to you and when we got together I
remember one time you tried to push me
down the stairs I won't deny that I also
won't agree that that's true Michael and
my younger sister Raven got along fine
I'm over here fighting for Michael's
attention and Michael's over here
fighting for Raven on behalf of middle
children everywhere I would say to older
and younger siblings just ease up on the
middle children a little bit we're very
sensitive we just want to love you we
just want you to love us my biggest
advice for any middle child out there
find a creative way to get attention my
coping mechanism for trying to get
attention was being as good as possible
in athletics so I literally played every
sport my high school had to offer I was
on the soccer team volleyball team a
basketball team I ran track and I made
sure my parents were at every possible
event loudly you are gonna watch me were
gonna watch me be great to get my
parents attention I took on acting and
singing and things like that I did a lot
of school plays of inevitably my parents
would have to come to them and watch me
perform and I would get all the
attention that day in school I was a
really good student since you aren't
given the opportunity to just be your
own person that you start doing things
that are very unique you want to make a
statement little children are
trendsetters they're the pioneers
they're the ones that are gonna go out
and make something happen
even when it's never been done middle
children are a handful but they're going
to be one
biggest gifts and you're gonna get the
most out of them I feel like being a
middle child comes with its perks
because nobody's paying attention to you
you kind of get to do like some things
under the radar I didn't have to be the
first to do everything and my parents
were able to get out all of their first
parent stuff with my brother when it
came to me they're a little bit more
lenient and a little bit more loose
being the middle child there was
pressure to follow the footsteps of my
brothers and sisters in front of me and
I did not adhere to that I think I
figured out 200 and later that this was
my life and especially for my culture my
background being in Geryon of that was
not the script that I was supposed to
follow my parents were really really big
on education when it came to college I
was like I'll do it and then when I was
there I was like I want something more
so I left and that was the biggest shock
to have my family ever I was the first
and only child to this day to ever make
the decision to walk away from college
being a middle child I had the
opportunity to be me and I think when
you're older you don't have that
opportunity I think you have an
expectation to represent the family
first that's the middle child you're
given a lot of space to sort of like
create your own identity away from like
your family because my family is really
traditional Mexican there was a lot of
things that I sort of broke the rules in
I was a first child to move out at 18
because I was the first child to go to
college being a vegetarian that's
something unheard of in a Mexican
American family when I was vegetarian I
went to Mexico everywhere you go in my
parents little town there's street tacos
I really wanted tacos but I was a
vegetarian so what I did was that I had
tacos made of like lettuce and carrots
and that is an ongoing joke my family
still jokes about that today as the
middle child I definitely felt like the
mediator within my entire family I
definitely think I bring the family
together
oh he's gonna provide a good time he's
either gonna end up DJ the party for us
is that end of mixing drinks for us he's
gonna make sure we're laughing or joking
and we're having fun my family trips
I've kind of had to balance everyone out
make sure everyone was having a good
time and I think that's a role that the
middle child usually takes on I wouldn't
change it for the world
one thing that people really know about
middle children is if you really need
them any tell them that they'll be there
for you they will not let you down I
like now that we're older than we're all
adults the three of us are all on the
same playing field when we all get
together we're just goofy as [ __ ]
we don't make sense we're all pretty
close now and we like to play board
games and things like that even though
there were five of us we felt like love
or my homies are my best friends because
we knew our parents were working hard
just to provide for us so we always had
each other and that was enough
[Music]